hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about tinnitus another mechanism of what
causes it okay now the inner ear and the
brain have no glycogen storage unit in
other words both areas are dependent on
the sugar in the blood okay so that's
one thing and when you have high levels
of sugar and high levels of insulin
insulin really comes first and then high
levels of sugar become a diabetic what
happens there's four areas to the body
that get destroyed one is the kidney one
is the brain when as a heart and one of
the nervous system that's why you get
peripheral neuropathy your fingers and
your toes you start getting numbness and
tingling and then eventually it starts
to creating problems with the vascular
system so there's a whole series of
things that happen so when you have high
sugar high insulin what happens that
tends to deplete nutrients in the
tissues specifically B vitamins b1 okay
and then you start having all these
symptoms okay so there's a couple
studies I'm going to put a link down
below of the relationship between
tinnitus which is basically destruction
of the nerves in the inner ear in
creating this ringing sensation which
drives people crazy I believe it's the
the high sugar that's causing the
destruction of the nerves so if it's
going to affect the brain which it does
it's going to affect the inner ear as
well another study showed that eighty
four percent of people with tinnitus had
high levels of insulin but they never
check for insulin doctors never check
for a fasting insulin test so if you
have tinnitus ask your doctor to test
the insulin levels okay and see if it's
high so now what do we do about it I'm
gonna recommend doing two things one is
to go out and find a good source of fat
soluble B vitamin called benfotiamine
okay benfotiamine you can get it online
or at the health of store but it is a an
amazing fat soluble vitamin that
innervates
the nerves to help heal the nerves from
high sugar or high insulin the damage
from these two secondly you need to do
healthy ketosis in a minute fasting
that's going to ultimately correct this
problem right here so you can then
restore it but you definitely are going
to need the benfotiamine to actually
speed up the process alright thanks for
watching hey I appreciate your attention
and if you're enjoying these videos go
ahead and subscribe and I will
definitely keep you updated on future
events live events and webinars that
we're going to do very soon